we have a little quiz a little game show
I want you to know I want to know where
this mechanical problem is a science
fiction problem or a real-life real
mechanical mechanical problem real or
not is it okay
all right there we go being a man yes so
is it a real thing is it a real thing in
real life if you have a cracked harmonic
balancer uh yeah you can be cracked
Rahman it yeah
I'd I would say it's science fiction you
have Monica Lee balance or crankshaft
and things you're exactly right it is a
real coughing the harmonic balancer is a
device connected to the crankshaft of an
engine to reduce torsional vibration and
serves as a pulley for drive belts and
now I have more questions than that
actually answered I pay attention to
when they want to have to pay to get my
car fixed I've never broken my harmonic
no no they're usually geared they're
very very high rel high reliability
they're okay well Beth but Neil you like
this yeah the rate of change of position
is ah debts velocity rate of change of
velocity acceleration so the rate of
change of acceleration is a jerk and
that's what will make that okay cool
yeah forensics stuff going on there yes
all right
would it be a real wait just just to be
clear so rate of change of position is
speed or velocity and we've all familiar
with being in a constant velocity when
you're at constant velocity you don't
feel it so now if you're accelerating
and you're positioned yourself and you
all your muscles are resisting the
constant acceleration then you have a
change in the acceleration that's a jerk
so you feel it and then you punch the
brake some more then you'll feel a jerk
forward that's why it's appropriately
called a jerk so what else you have all
right what about defective planetary
gears sure defective planetary yes yeah
yeah planetary gears where you have a
Sun gear and planet gears I didn't know
anything about it you have a three-speed
bicycle you have a planetary gear train
that is exactly it they're the primary
case with an automatic transmission
okay very good all right
what have you had an unmotivated binary
motivator it sounds like science fiction
to me us straight-up correct that isn't
Star Wars this device in Troy okay tell
me one more what do we have a damp flux
capacitor that is of course real so
there was a documentary called Back to
the Future I highly recommend it I think
is on new bike